so what are the bookies saying Matt well
the bookies are now putting the odds at
four to five I'm sorry five to four
instead of five to one so previously any
$1 bet would have netted you $5 now any
$4 bet will net you $5 so your payback
isn't gonna be so great because the
bookies think it's more likely that the
World Cup in Qatar will be cancelled the
reason obviously is Sepp Blatter's
second stepping down he was the main
force behind this bid staying on I mean
ever since 2010 when FIFA awarded Qatar
the World Cup in 2022 most people were
saying it was absolutely insane I mean
the country has no soccer history it
gets up to temperatures of 120 to 140
degrees during the summer when a World
Cup will be held and spending to build
the eight stadiums necessary to host the
event would have to top 200 billion
dollars so it makes absolutely no sense
at all to anyone else but apparently set
Blatter and the other members of FIFA
most of whom have been arrested or
indicted so now that he's stepped down
the likelihood of that being pulled is a
little bit higher having said that this
country has already spent a heck of a
lot of money to build this they're gonna
spend 35 billion dollars on a subway and
metro station alone they've built a city
north of Doha for 200000 occupants at
least for 200,000 tourists who come to
watch the World Cup and they've had
serious problems with migrant workers a
lot of accusations of human rights
violations 1,200 migrant workers have
died since the start of this and a union
trade group says that it expects another
4,000 union workers are migrant workers
to die before the World Cup happens so I
think a lot of people would be happy to
see the World Cup pulled out of katar
the players probably not in the least
because the entire European soccer
league so had to change their schedules
to work around a schedule change for the
2022 World Cup if they pull it from
Qatar essentially you can go back to a
normal schedule for Premier League for
Bundesliga soccer and then of course it
makes a lot more sense to have it in a
country that would be easier and
more climate-friendly country to visit
with with fewer human rights violations
so the question is what's gonna happen
going forward we obviously have no idea
this is a news story that just broke
Sepp Blatter resigning he previously had
said over and over again it would never
be pulled and if this bid gets pulled
the question is what happens to the
Russia bid right Russia is supposed to
host the World Cup in 2018 and the FBI
have said they are investigating at
least looking into the possibility that
that bid or this bid were won through
bribery but if they pulled a bid from
Russia the 2018 bid I mean that would
cause a serious international incident
as for 2022 and Qatar perhaps not
staying with the World Cup some people
have speculated or floated the idea of
maybe the US would make a good host
given its leading role in this
corruption scandal as well I mean this
is just what I read on Twitter that they
would the the new members or the new
leaders of people would then just award
it to the United States I agree that it
would be a lot more fun to have it here
in the u.s. garlotte where was it last
good idea right I don't that was been
70s right know that there was a World
Cup in 1994 1998 I remember something
like that in 1990 here in the US I'm
sure someone can tweet me about this
because they're much more on top of this
than I am on the World Cup specifically
but we'll keep an eye on this